play i sold was beetlejuice that was the
first one
it was finished I had a very good
relationship with a very prominent
studio head who shall remain nameless
and and when Beetlejuice was finished I
gave it to him to read on a Friday and
he said I'm happy to read it and I got a
call on a Monday that he wanted to meet
with me and I thought oh my gosh you
know he read it he must love it or he
would not be summoning me to his office
so quickly and I went into his office
and he said to me Larry what are you
doing he said you have actually a very
good future as an as an executive as a
producer this piece of crap is going to
sink you and sink your career why would
you put this on the marketplace
representing you and he said it's weird
it makes no sense it's not commercial
and I left that meeting as you can
imagine to say to say a little taken
aback a little uh that we would be
putting it mildly he could not
understand why I would want this bizarre
piece of junk representing me and but I
had also given it to because I've taught
for like 25-30 years primarily at UCLA
and I was teaching a story analysis
class at that time and I had a student
named Marjorie Lewis and I thought she
was the smartest young woman in my class
and she had a low-level development job
at the Geffen company and I'd given it
her to her to read only to see what she
thought because I really had learned to
value her opinion and so coming out of
this meeting
feeling very bad about myself I called
Marjorie and I said did you read it she
said yes I read it and I said did you
like it and she said liked it I'm gonna
get the Geffen company to buy it and and
knowing Marjorie what she did was that
she just put it on peoples desk and she
was so tenacious and she was so annoying
that people just finally said okay we'll
read it will read it and and that's how
it got to the Geffen Company and that's
how it got read and Marjorie is probably
like I say probably one of two unsung
heroes of that film
and-and-and the Geffen Company proceeded
to buy it for our asking price on my god
which was incredible and then on it went
Walter Hill I left paramount I went to
work for Walter Hill and the Phoenix
company and and Walter was one of the
producers of alien the first alien film
and Anna's partner and and my my two
bosses David Kyler was another one on
the producers and when I went to work
for them the one of the first things I
said to me one of the primary things
that your job is going to be is to find
us a writer for the alien sequel and I
and I without going into detail certain
promises were made to me if I found that
writer good things would happen we'll
just leave it at that and I met with Jim
Cameron and that this that this is I I
I'm going to say I discovered Jim
Cameron for aliens and that's pretty
true but if you had my job and Jim
McCann this was I believe that
Terminator was maybe in pre-production
or post-its is long enough I don't
remember but Terminator was was not out
there but if you read the script of
Terminator and met Jim Cameron and you
didn't think that he was going to be the
Jim Cameron you didn't deserve my job so
this was this was hardly like a great
insight on my part you just met met Jim
and he was a force of nature and you
could just feel the talent but it still
was a hard sell because he had a he had
a not very good movie called piranha to
that that you know that I had to show
people and this was back in the day when
you had to set up a projector and you
know in an office and and and hope all
the light wasn't bleeding and and but I
just but anyway that it was it was
a bit of a struggles a bit of a fight
but Jim not only became the writer
obviously but the director of aliens and
I went to my bosses and said okay I
think I did my job I think I not only
brought the writer to the project I
brought the director to the project look
what I did and they said yes you did so
what and it was enough I I just felt and
I'd had an experience at Paramount with
a film called young Sherlock Holmes
which was a regional idea of mine and as
an executive there we were under so much
pressure to bring in ideas that I did
something I told myself I was never
gonna do because I sort of had a little
file of ideas that one day if I write
again I'm gonna write and that was one
of them and I brought that in and there
were a lot of promises made to me if
that got made great things would happen
and it did get made written by Chris
Columbus and I I just I I just realized
and also I just I was a writer I mean
that's who I was and I'd let that go and
I had allowed myself to suffer a classic
case of writer's block and and I just
said I'm gonna be a writer again and I
got I got very blessed having my new
partner Michael McDonald who was as
professional a writer as I'd ever come
across and working with him inspired me
challenged me made me understand what it
truly meant to be a writer and a
screenwriter and a screenwriter with a
career and I and and women when and and
the the epiphany was actually I don't
want to I want to be a writer again and
I'm just kind of selling myself short
and selling my talent short by not doing
it and get over the fear and and do it
maybe this is a good story for aspiring
screenwriters out there when I when I
went to work with with Michael McDowell
on Beetlejuice we had been working for a
couple of weeks and he sat down with me
and he said Larry this is not working
out this is not happening and I was
taken aback and I said why what do you
mean he said because you're just sitting
around waiting for inspiration and I
don't work like that I'm not I'm not
gonna sit around waiting for you to be
inspired if you're gonna work with me
and Michael was this professional writer
as I ever met he had published I don't
know
19 20 novels or novels Jean Grae genre
novels he had written for a show called
tales from the dark side he was the real
deal and and and and and not a not not a
pro not not a person to to hold back his
feelings okay any any and again he said
to me this is just not happening and and
he said and this was the most this
changed my my life as a writer he said
if you're gonna work with me look at it
like we're working in a bank we get in
at 9:00 we have a cup of coffee we say
good morning we then we go to work and
we were and we write until lunch we go
have our lunch we come back we write
again until around three o'clock in the
afternoon we fold up the writing we
return whatever phone calls whatever
business of writing we have to do and we
do this five six days a week and we're
and and and it's a job it's it's it's
not you sitting in it with a
metaphorical beret in a metaphorical
loft waiting for inspiration to strike
it's a job and it was a bit of tough
love and it took me aback
and and I was I suppose a tiny bit
offended but then then the thing he said
to me that sealed the deal because I
when I was working at Paramount I was
writing script notes again it was it was
like a 16-hour day often and in probably
fourteen of those hours a day we was
writing script notes and he said Larry
you've told me you've written hundreds
of pages of notes for other people's
scripts why can't you do it for yourself
and I was like wow okay I will try it
your way
and it changed my perception of who a
writer is what a writer does and it
changed my work habits and it changed
everything and I did it his way and I
took all of that all and he was
absolutely right all of that discipline
that I'd put into other people's work I
put in I started put into my work our
work and and and and it was and and
Beetlejuice came out of that and is
crazy and you know and as far out as
that movie is the script was written in
a very disciplined way because that was
the way Michael needed to work
and I decided I was going to be a writer
again and decided I was going to do it
with Michael in my mind I said to myself
I sense so powerful maybe but I'm gonna
write a classic well I'm not just gonna
write another movie we are going to
create a classic and who knows what that
means and again it sounds obnoxious
maybe but we knew probably I don't know
20-some pages in that just something was
happening and we weren't thinking about
demographics we weren't thinking about
who the audience was going to be we
weren't thinking about any any
quote-unquote commercial aspects of it
we were thinking what's good what's
funny what's making us laugh what's
moving the story forward what are the
zany as craziest ideas we can have and
it just and it happens with with with
scripts and it happens in your writing
there's just times that you feel that
you're in a zone and you're in a place
that you're so connecting with yourself
and you're so connecting with what your
vision is that if you can get on a page
other people are gonna see it and feel
it too and that movie was was that and
we didn't know what was going to happen
with it when the movie was finished
there were people Warner Brothers in the
marketing department who absolutely
hated it they wanted to change the title
the house ghost and dump it and back in
the days when you'd put it in a thousand
theaters or something and let it run a
week and then hopefully it would go away
that wasn't everyone and we had David
Geffen on our side so we were protected
but it was hardly loved
but I knew who we were writing it for
and and in my mind and this is very 80s
reference there was a band there's still
a bad The Cure the great cure and I
loved and I gone to see them at the Rose
Bowl huge concert maybe fifty thousand
people and it felt to me like it was
fifty thousand teenage girls in black
right you know and and and that was and
and and that when an erotic character
Lydia came out of that and I always that
I thought that's who the audience for
this movie is and as we were writing it
and and III that for me and it may have
been different for Michael but that was
always who I thought this movie was
being written for and and it's really a
family story and it's about a girl who
needs a mom and a dad and and and and
because her real mom and dad just don't
understand her don't spend enough time
with her so she ends up with two ghosts
that's the heart of that movie and
that's what I was riding towards and the
must and and that so so finally its its
release and I go to see it nearby where
we're sitting now at Universal on a
Friday night it's the first Friday night
and I watch it with an audience a real
audience for the first time in Chris
there's been some test audiences and all
of that and people are coming out of it
either loving it or hating it which I
thought great that's exactly what we
wanted and that was that was Friday
night then Saturday night I went back
and I saw a bunch of teenage girls who
had gone into their closet having seen
it on Friday night and came back dressed
like window writer Lydia Deetz and I
thought okay
it's a hit we have connected with the
audience to the point that they're
already dressing up as Lydia and then
there was a marketing meeting at Warner
Brothers it may have been on the Monday
and it had surpassed everyone's
expectations in terms of the grosses and
and and and the the audience feedback
and it was obvious that that was that it
was going to take off and be something
special and again in in this no-name
zone there was a marketing person who I
always remember as a guy who would wear
a scarf no matter what the temperature
was okay and and and it was I remember
Tim Burton being there and David Geffen
being there and the Michaels and myself
and this marketing person all he could
say all he could the best he could do
was well at least we got the little
girls in black to come see it and we
walked out of the meeting and Tim said
well who the eff did we think he made it
for yeah who do you think we made it for
and and it was just a and and and one
thing when things are going well in my
writing and I think it's true for all
writers that if you're like intensely
self-conscious about who is your
audience who who is it you know is this
for the 12 to 16 year old if you're
doing that you're not writing well and
you get in a zone and your story starts
telling you you're not telling the story
it's emerging from someplace within you
and that's what Beetlejuice was and I
just always had and I used to say to
Michael sometimes because I could feel
it going well and I'd say Michael you
know we're gonna have a toy line he'd go
shut up shut up let's just finish the
script you know but III mean it's a very
hard thing to explain what the
what that what that it's it's an
epiphany after enough fifity and that
you feel like you're just on to
something bigger than you you know
what that story is and and you know it's
not that cliche right what you know
because I've never written what I quote
unquote know I I write fantastical
world's and and and and and supernatural
stories and all of that but write what
you feel and write what's in your heart
and write something that means something
to you and you know I I was a script
reader for God probably a decade and I
and the and and I was reading seven
eight scripts a week and the rare one
was the great script and when you found
that that was a very exciting day at the
office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were fun
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really innovating as a script reader
who's sitting there and has to read a
script synopsize that write a comment
about it then pick up another one and
read it and tonight were the ones that
you could tell we're written by people
who were looking at what last year's hit
was and trying to imitate it and those
were deadly and they were they weren't
good they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think that Beetlejuice is a personal
movie it's an intensely personal movie
it was intensely personal for Michael me
and and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together in some bizarre
way but there but but because I came
from a broken family
and and what and and and so so the
there's a III like to think that my work
has a sense of heart in a sense of
compassion and a sense of humanity in it
no matter how bizarre it is no matter
how weird the worlds get and and you you
got you got to write something that you
feel on something that you have some
passion for or just why do it it's too
hard it's just it's it's it's it's not
an easy job and and I personally can't
imagine saying well this was a hit now
so I'm gonna I'm gonna write my version
and that I don't really it's not really
what I care about what I feel but I can
imitate it well enough I can't imagine
spending a year of your life
doing that but people do it all the time
and they usually write me do Chris Krebs
there's an idea and usually what I know
is I know
beetlejuice for instance the idea was
that I discussed with my partners a
psychedelic ghost comedy we had no idea
what that meant but it rolled off the
tongue right and and and and I usually
have something of an idea like that and
I kind of know the beginning and I kind
of know the end the middle is the great
unknown but but but but it's it's an
instinct and an idea and sometimes it's
a character and sometimes it's a
situation but it's very it's very
internal at first and and and yes
there's times where you write an
assignment you know and and and you're
you're you're given an idea and say
translate this into a movie but in terms
of my my own my own writing if you will
my my personal writing it usually comes
from front from just the most basic kind
of idea and a feeling you know and and
and it's like and I can't articulate it
very well I'm sorry because it's hard to
articulate but it's just kind of like
again like a situation and our character
that's just kind of waiting to come out
and then you whatever you whatever your
process is and boy do you need a process
and boy do you need to go to work and
boy do you need to sit down and do it
and do the job of writing and and and
you allow that that character or that
situation to just start growing and
start coming you know leaving your
fingers on to the digital page these
days you know on your computer and then
it grows and expands and it takes on
life and and you know I there's
of course and this is the this is every
writers choice there's a lot of talk
about backstory always you know like
like tell it you know where did your
character go to school how it you know
what was his or her mommy like and all
of that I've never written a back story
in my life never but if you ask me to
tell me the back story of one of my
characters I could I'd kind of be making
it up as I went along but the feelings
would be true because I feel I I feel
the characters and I and and I feel like
they need to come out and I feel like
they need to be given a voice and and
that's just that that that's that's what
writing is to me a a idea or a character
or situation or an emotion or a feeling
that that that you somehow have to put
into the world and it's hard to
articulate it and I feel like I'm
talking in circles but I but it's it's
just it's almost hard not to because
it's so it's so insane
you know I I hope that makes some
version of sense
I kind of know and anything but that can
all change but people get very scared of
the middle but for me that's when it
gets fun because it's so challenging and
you so get to what you know in a
screenplay if you think of a screenplay
is a hundred and ten hundred and twenty
pages you get to page sixty and you go
oh my god I'm only half way there
what happens next but but something will
happen and and I and that's exhilarating
and it's exhilarating to go to bed
completely sure that you will never
figure out what's going to happen next
and wake up with the answer and that and
and and it and it's you know it's it's
it's it's a daily challenge but it's a
it's so it feel it feels so good to
realize that that next scene will be
there if you keep working at it there's
there's it's the best feeling in the
world other than finishing and then
finishing this like the first draft no
matter what shape it's in as like
brilliant I mean that's just I always
get tears in my eyes when I finish a
first draft because I feel like I'm
saying goodbye to a group of people that
I'd been on this journey with and and
and there's a there's a very emotional
side to it and then you know then you
become the craftsman and time for a
second draft and all of that but it's
it's an it's an emotional journey and to
do that day after day it's it's
incredibly rewarding and I've got the
best job in the world
I will go back I will never go back to
the beginning because that is a death
trap I know what I'll do I'll go back
and rewrite the first 60 pages and then
I'll go back gonna rewrite the first 60
pages again and again I'll go back and
read a couple of pages and and and maybe
do some cosmetic stuff just to get you
know just to put myself back into the
zone of the story and then you just and
then I just start writing and they may
not be good ideas there may be my my
drafts are always 2030 pages too long
when I finished the first draft because
I'm telling the story to myself but I I
forget who it was I'm gonna say Oscar
Wilde I'm gonna say son famous writer
said just sit down and start typing your
name over and over even Oscar Wilde may
been pre typewriter I bet but but you
understand the point start typing your
name start doing anything with your
fingers and I and again it's it's like
where that comes from
and where that next scene comes from
it's there it is there and if you put
yourself in a position to find it you
will find it and I might spend the day
writing ten basically bad pages but
there'll be one page of truth in it and
one one moment that will move the story
forward and and Stephen King talks about
this really brilliantly and he I have
questions about outlining and I'm not
here to have an outline debate
he's scathing about outlining if you've
ever read his book on writing great
probably the best book I'm writing ever
written into my mind but he always says
it's what happens next it's what happens
next what happens next one happens next
and you know if I were to reach across
the room
here and and still your pay your notes
from you there would be a response yes
dad or if I were to kick the camera over
and say I'm done with this interview
there would be a response right and then
it's what happens next do you jump on me
and say give me my notes back you jerk
do you I mean and it's really that is it
kind of gets it and if you just look at
it like that that that and you look at
it like like whatever whatever you made
happen something has to happen next and
it's what happens next what happens next
what happens next what happens next that
what happens next will come and it may
not come easily and there may be a lot
of like I said bad what happens next
before you write find the right what
happens next but it'll come and it's it
and it's it's it's a magical process
I mean magical in the sense that that
it's it's almost unexplainable and it's
why and it's why there's so many
screenwriting programs and apps and and
and all of these things out there to
kind of tell you that they can tell you
what happens next but they can't tell
you what happens next only you can tell
you what happens next and I look at as a
moment-by-moment process and I put these
characters in a situation and it's often
diabolical and it's often otherworldly
and they've got to get themselves either
deeper into it or get the hell out of it
and that's the journey and and it's
moment by moment and it's and it's it's
sort of literally second-by-second if
you think about it you know movies move
forward in a linear fashion and it's
just and it's just tracking that and and
and and putting your character and and
when it really gets fun is when you put
your character in the most difficult out
that that that that is probably the the
an illustration that I use about this
all the time
teach the very first class I always say
and I make this statistic up depending
on how I'm feeling the room I will say
98% of you will fail and people go and I
say you'll fail because you'll never
finish you will never finish your script
and and sad but true I'm I'm not wrong
I'm pretty darn close and I've taught
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
students at this point and not finishing
is exactly what most people will do I
just have I've just been teaching a
workshop where I've given people 12
weeks to finish a draft that they've
been working on for a long time and the
dropout rate is enormous and this is
exactly what you said this is
perfectionism and this isn't not
allowing yourself the ability to fail
and it's a huge mistake
you you have to you know baseball
metaphors get tossed around a lot in the
screenwriting trade because they kind of
fit in a way like if you're batting 300
you're doing great but that means you're
hitting the ball once every three times
right and and and and but to go back to
this what happens next idea and how I
you know and you you would said you wake
up a Monday morning with your cup of
coffee and you've gone to work and you
have no idea what what needs to happen
next in your script was story I tell
about this almost always in my classes
was from Beetlejuice where there's a
scene that a lot of people love actually
it's it's become like a lot of people
one of their favorite scenes and the
ghost Barbara Barbara and Adam Geena
Davis and Alec Baldwin they've died
they've driven off a bridge trying to
avoid a dog aren't they good people they
tried to avoid the doggie and they drove
it off a bridge and they've drown
and they're trapped in their house now
as ghosts and they've been given a book
about how to how the handbook for the
recently deceased that they can't make
that they can't figure it out and they
want to go into the afterlife and ask
questions about how to be ghosts and how
they're supposed to live it you know
live as ghosts the daya's goes whatever
and and but but what Michael my writing
partner Michael McDowell I had done is
we had trapped them so well in their
house we had no idea how to get them
into the afterlife we had done a very
good job of sticking them there what
would what felt like no exit and we had
to come up with a way for them to get
out of the house and the dynamic between
you got to understand Michael was I'm
gonna say harvard-educated if not
Harvard some incredibly prestigious
university I I grew up in a trailer park
and barely got out of high school okay
there was there there was there were
there was a sometimes it was usually
usually playful but sort of a status
issue between us and and and the way we
had often work is that I would like
vomit out ideas and he would just start
shooting them down and it was always one
word no no no no and we were trying to
come up with a way to get them out of
the house Barbara and Adam the ghosts
get them into the afterlife and I was
coming up with more and more convoluted
ideas about how to get them out of the
down house and I'm sure trying to bring
out my supernatural chops and all that I
knew about you know metaphysics and
blotted Eve law just to get them out of
the house and every idea I came up with
no no no and my ideas kept getting
further and further out and more
convoluted no no no and I finally got
really angry with Michael and I said
Michael what do you want them to do draw
an effing door and I just said it
because I thought it was a stupidest
idea imaginable
and I was so mad I says that what you
want you want them to draw a door and he
just started laughing and when I started
laughing and we said yes that's exactly
what they should do is draw a door so
rather than these incredibly like these
convoluted supernatural nonsense Adam
found a piece of chalk drew a door drew
a doorknob opened it and went into the
afterlife simple but it took all of that
convoluted stuff to get there and that's
what will happen when you sit down and
you're stuck you will write and write
and write and you won't think you found
it and and you'll know you haven't found
it but if you keep at it and you'll keep
writing they'll finally be that epiphany
moment you'll go oh that's what's
happens next and then you will write
that and you will have moved your
characters forward one more step in your
story and then the next what happens
next is in front of your eyes and you
move forward like that and it's
sometimes it's literally moving an inch
or less than an inch at a time and
sometimes it's running sometimes it's
crawling sometimes - what happens next
happen really quickly and you have a day
where you just go oh my god you know I
just I just you know I just wrote ten
great pages and all they need is just a
little a little sprucing up and they're
there and some days you will write 10
pages and you will have maybe a quarter
of a page as usable but you will have
moved the story forward that much and
it's it's a kind of alchemy a kind of a
magic of creation but it's such a
beautiful feeling that's the best job in
the world
one thing that I love doing when I'm
doing workshops is having like a free
write and I will pick something a topic
something that's happened to me that a
week or or something that's that's
either like making me really happy or
really bothering me be in the world it
can be personal and all of that and I
will ask people to write just like let's
spend the first half hour of the class
just writing about that and and that
could be I was on the phone yesterday
and before I knew it I was saying things
that I really regret and I couldn't take
back have you have you been on the phone
and said things to someone who you
really care about that you really regret
and and and you can't take back and of
course everyone has and people will
write and because again I I will be sort
of ruthlessly honest with myself it'll
give people permission to be honest with
themselves and and and some of the most
amazing writing I've had come out of my
workshops are those free rights and and
and it's and it's writing there's gonna
be so much rejection there's going to be
so much indifference there's going to be
there's gonna be so so many people
saying no other people do that you don't
do that you know other people make
movies you don't make movies I I was I
was with a very talented writer or
director on on Sunday night it was from
Georgia I was talking about when he said
to his family he was moving to New York
to make movies he said I might as well
been saying I'm going to Mars to
colonize the red
you know I mean no that's what other
people do that a kid from Georgia
doesn't do that and and I just try to
convince people that that just relax oh
my god relax just write it don't worry
about it yeah that some people will hate
it
some people will love it beetle to
beetle just got a lot of terrible
reviews they were wrong I I was told by
one of the most prominent executives in
Hollywood I was ruining my career he was
wrong people but what what so what if
they're right
you'll write another one and and and I
and I love doing free writes I love
saying reveal a little something about
yourself this is a safe place and it's
amazing what comes out if people give
themselves permission to do that but
it's hardly a perfect process and and so
many people will be so afraid of how
they're gonna be judged by their words
on a computer screen for god sakes it's
a screenplay okay it's a f'n screenplay
get over it you know I mean but they
will be so afraid of how they're gonna
be judged and how they're gonna be
judged of failure that they'll just quit
and they'll figure out something else to
do so I try I try and I try to just
loosen people up and say feel feel free
to fail I started surfing again a couple
of years ago after after 40 years of not
doing it and I was a really good surfer
40 years ago and I started again I was
terrible I mean I says everything I
thought I knew I I you know I I knew it
in principle but I had to learn again
and then all of a sudden I started
getting good again but it was after a
lot of falling off a surfboard and
embarrassing myself
but it's it's it's that it's that same
thing you fall off you fall off you fall
off and then you don't and that's and
writing is you're gonna write badly
you're gonna write badly and then you're
gonna write good
when I became a city of executive
paramount working most closely with Jeff
Katzenberg it was all of a sudden there
was this that this as these bizarre
trends happen and you don't quite
understand where they come from and then
why they go away but all of a sudden
became very important to hire people in
development positions who had a Harvard
education and I was working with a
couple of them and and and they also
went to the school of Makaveli I guess
and dad had read a reread the art of war
and and and on strategically on that
level they could kill me dead okay but I
thought about it and I thought I've
loved movies since I remember and while
I was terrible in school I was a
terrible student
my mom loved reading and she taught me a
love of reading so I had that on my side
but what I really had on my side was if
I loved a movie I loved I loved it and
if I and I realized pretty quickly that
the movies the movie business it was not
a business meant for Harvard grads and I
could read a script and say this is a
movie and say it with as much confidence
as possible and and and mean it and
believe it and I but I was up against
this I this this and and my own
inferiority complex sometimes about not
having been a good student and not
having you know barely gotten out of
high school it would work on me
sometimes but one day after I'd been
cooked completely creamed it in a
in a development war with with one of
these Harvard grads Jeff Katzenberg took
me aside and he said Larry you need to
learn to be a straight player in a
crooked game I'm not here for you to out
manipulate anyone you're sitting with me
and you have and you're sitting beside
me here because when you love something
you love it and when you read a script
and you love it you're gonna make sure
that you that that that everyone else
loves it too
and and and that's what I like in you
and that's why you're valuable to me
stop trying to be a studio executive be
a guy who can read a script or watch a
movie and get excited the way you get
excited and that that was a huge shot in
the arm of confidence that I that I took
away and III Oh Jeff Katzenberg
gratitude for a lot of things that he
wouldn't even be aware of but that was a
big one because he told me just be
yourself and use this passion for movies
in this love for movies and make that
your calling card don't try to be a
player you're not good at it you're
horrible at it which I am because I wear
everything on my sleeve ask my wife yeah
everyone has pitch nightmare stories and
they're true but it's really unfair to
development people in studio executives
who assume that everyone in those
meetings is there to make basically make
your life miserable and say no to you
it's not true and and wait and how you
contribute to it as a writer you come in
with an idea that you've actually
thought through and that you have some
passion for and and and and that also
you need to be willing to listen it's a
conversation and and the control you
have of the conversation is you're the
one coming in with the idea you're the
kind of you're the one coming in saying
hey I think this would be a great movie
this would be a great television show
whatever and you should have thought it
through and you should have prepared
well enough to when they say well why do
you think it's such a great idea to be
able to answer the questions and you
should know enough about your story that
that you can do it justice in the room
but then having sat as an executive I've
also been in those meetings where you
say to someone yeah I get it
but and they immediately what but there
is no but this is the story you have
nothing to say to me and and a defensive
'no scanned that's a huge mistake you
don't don't go to the meeting just write
the stupid script it's a conversation
and it's a dialogue and don't assume
that you know more than the person in
the room who you're speaking to have it
as a conversation and be strong and no
one you need to dig in your heels and
know that that there are they're there
that if people are changing your story
in the room so much that you don't even
recognize it anymore which could happen
that you need to say no and say thank
you for the meeting and Lee
but engage in the conversation have a
little bit of effing humility for God's
sakes you know you you've been invited
into the room that tells someone a story
you don't don't don't assume that they
that they don't have a thought in their
head and there are so many stories and
again a lot of them are true and I could
tell you nightmare stories about pitches
we could stay here all night and I can
tell you those stories but it's but I
could also tell you great stories with
great development people who have given
me enough rope to hang myself then said
that what if this happened or that
happened and they've given me a better
idea at a better take it's a dialogue
it's a conversation and it's part of the
it's part of the business and I hate to
call it a game but I will for a moment
it's part of the game but if you just
can't stand the idea of going in and
telling the story and someone's going to
try to change it or have an idea write
the script
don't be a pitch monkey be a
screenwriter
there was this this time where
everything was supposed to be based on
Joseph Campbell remember those days when
everything you had to go in you know and
and and that was what you were supposed
to that was what you were you were
always if you were gonna pitch you were
you were gonna you you were gonna you
were gonna pitch something and you
Joseph Campbell was gonna end up in the
sentence and I was going in with a
producer who said now remember to get
the Joseph Campbell moments in there and
I was pitching I was about three minutes
into it and the guy across the desk said
oh Jesus Christ can we get over the
Joseph Campbell stuff can you just tell
me the story and the meeting died a
horrible death and I should never have
done it I should have just said here's
the story
and if you see Joseph Campbell in it
good for you but but those are those
things don't don't trick yourself just
go ahead and tell the best story that
you can
you write a really really good
screenplay and the metaphysics of
getting a meeting after that are so
elusive sorry I'm not a and it's a very
sincere question and I it gets asked to
me all the time
and I'm going so I'm gonna dance around
it a little bit but I'm gonna but again
not seriously but sincerely there was a
time when I was teaching and that here's
something about me me as a teacher I am
AI I'm a screenwriting teacher who's not
a failed screenwriter I'm actually a
successful screenwriter who teaches at
the same time oh god that was cheap I
apologize but I I stopped I stopped
teaching at one point because I really
had an ethical dilemma because I thought
the real reason people were taking my
classes is to say to me how do you get a
movie made you've gotten movies made
you've gotten through the door how do I
get through the door and I could have
been teaching anything that could story
analysis screenplay structure dialogue
anything and I thought the real reason
that people were there was to ask me
Larry Wilson how do I get a pitch
meaning how do I get a movie mate how do
I get through the door and I didn't know
what to say I didn't know what to say
and I felt like I was like part of this
false hope machine and I didn't like it
and I didn't like the way it made me
feel and I stopped teaching and the
thing that brought me back to teaching
and where I could do it again were a
question like that which I wish I had a
great answer
III look I've I've been blessed by the
fact that doors open unexpected doors
open for me my entire
life after I moved to Hollywood I was
working in a department store stocking
makeup because I'd worked because I'd
cleaned my mother's beauty shop for
years and I knew how to stock makeup and
the woman who loved the way I stalked
her makeup said always say you want to
be in like the the entertainment
business well you should do cue cards
and she introduced me to a man named
Barney McNulty and the next thing I knew
was I was doing cue cards and all the
biggest television shows of the time a
door open I can't explain why that
happened why I went in stocking makeup
in that door open lock and all of that
it's too complex of a question but and
but I knew it was what people were
asking I hope this is making sense I
know so what people were asking me
really how do I get through the door how
do how do I get my script read by
someone that matters well there's some
easy Pat answers to that they're not Pat
but you know there's there's there's
contest there's pit for geezers all that
you know these millions of things out
there that you need to be careful about
what you submit to but there's all those
ways but there is no answer the question
but the and and I got very I I really
started I had an ethical dilemma about
it I did not want to be trafficking in
false hope and then I had some magical
answer so the first part of the answer
is write a really great scrub but the
reason I was able to come back to
teaching was the digital revolution and
the fact that you could make a movie
holding up my cell phone ladies and
gentlemen you can make a movie on your
cell phone now you can make a movie for
a thousand bucks there is no excuse for
you not to make a movie anymore and
knowing that and knowing that I could go
in and help people write a great
screenplay
and that they and if no one would give
them the time of day they could figure
out how to write a great screenplay that
they could shoot for five hundred
dollars on their iPhone inspired me to
come back to teaching and the answer is
there is no answer the answer is you
you put yourself in every possible place
conceivable place you can think of
without getting ripped off by sham
screenplay contest and all you put
yourself in every conceivable place you
can think of you submit your script
anywhere you possibly plant can you talk
to anyone who you think might be able to
help you and maybe that door will open
for you but if none of that works make
your own movie sorry you know I I and
and and and I and and it's it's it's
it's a great place to be but it's a
scary place for people to be when I
started in in the business a billion
years ago making a movie was expense
just a film stock could stop you from
making a movie the cost of printing and
developing and dailies and all of that
could stop you from making a movie that
wasn't that people didn't do it but it's
incredibly difficult but the digital
revolution if you can't get your stuff
seen if you can't get a pitch meeting
shoot a film shoot shoot a ten minute
short and post it on YouTube take your
career and your life into your own hands
and stop waiting for these gatekeepers
to give you permission to be a filmmaker
and you can at the same time you're
trying to get through that door and
you're trying to get that pitch meeting
and you're trying to get that huge movie
off the ground do all of that but be
making your your iPhone movie be and and
and and and it's an answer that people
don't want to hear why why do you think
they don't want to hear it because
because it puts all the responsibility
on them it makes them it makes them have
to make a movie it makes them have to do
something in public and perhaps fail it
makes them have to go to their mother
and say can I have a thousand bucks mom
why well I want to make a movie if you
think I'm going to spend a thousand
dollars I I mean you know it's it just
puts all the responsibility back on you
as a screenwriter and a filmmaker and
people hate that
they want that ticket that that is going
to open that door and I wish I had an
answer I have struggled with that
question for decades of teaching and I
don't know why these doors open for me
I don't know I know I was persistent I
was idiotically persistent I literally
was that that doofus who went around to
the guard gates at studios and said I
want to make a movie how do I make a
movie sir you know to a to a gate guard
I mean I literally did that because I
was so dumb I didn't know any better but
one of them finally said to me well son
what do you what do you do well I read
will then become a script reader how do
I do that well you ask someone and I got
a job $75 a week reading scripts and it
was and then I got it you know and then
I was like working you know in a
cosmetic counter and I'm a company in
that and I you know I mean it's just
stupid stuff that that's the way life
works or doesn't work for you but the
whole the whole landscape has changed
where anyone can make a movie now what
that means is there will be millions of
bad movies but make sure yours is a good
one and you know and and God here build
it and they will come or whatever that
is so that's the best answer I can give
and it's not
I wish question and ask her I could give
you a better answer but it's the only
answer I can honestly give you because I
don't know
I will if contractually obliged to doing
a beat sheet or an outline I will do it
and sometimes you are and what usually
happens is you spend all this time on
this beat sheet in this outline and it's
the most bastardize thing in the world
because it's not a script it's not a
story it's kind of this thing that
exists halfway between a script and a
story and I will but I'll do it if
contractually obliged to I'll do an
outline and I'll do a very detailed
outline and I'll do it always to the
best of my abilities I won't slum but
I'll do it and I'll hand it in and the
producers will go we love this outline
this is a great outline now go right to
script and you'll go write the script
and you'll have your outline you'll say
okay here's what the outline is telling
me and you'll start writing and it will
immediately start changing and better
ideas will emerge and the next thing you
know the outline is completely out the
window and you've written a script and
you'll turn it in and the producers or
go we love this this is just like the
outline and everyone's forgotten the
outline and I don't I know again my beat
sheet is I obviously you kind of know
the beginning you know you're putting
your characters and you feel these
characters and you put them in this
situation that they're gonna have to
fight for their lives to get out of I
kind of know what the end is going to be
kind of sort of and then it's the great
unknown and to do that in a beat sheet
to me it's just taking all the fun out
of it so don't don't don't listen to me
listen to all the other people out there
who say outline beat sheets please if
that's what you need to do and there's
great writers who do that of course they
do that but and and sometimes when
you're collaborating it becomes more
necessary because you're sending stuff
back and forth but for me I I they don't
work for me
and any time I do them everything starts
changing anyway so much that that they
quickly become irrelevant why don't they
work for you because that because I
I'm a storyteller and and the stories
emerge from someplace that that that is
Beach heatproof
that's just me maybe I don't know what I
mean they just they just come from
somewhere else and if I tell it all in
it you know in a quote-unquote beachy
it's like it's like why would I do that
to myself why would I why would I take
all the fun out of discovering it and
put it in this thing that's just kind of
bullet points it's just but that's me
and and that's the idiosyncratic part of
me but I'm in good company Stephen King
my favorite writer asked him about beat
sheets there's it but but you know help
me the writer who wrote Game of Thrones
the books thank you he said at the best
of anyone he said there are now you
would think particularly if you've read
the Game of Thrones books that those
things are outlined completely they're
so intricate they're so full of plot and
character and this needs to overlap and
this needs to you know I mean that
they're extremely intricate stories he
doesn't outline and what he says about
it is and I think it's such a great
quote and I'm paraphrasing a little bit
but it's the essence of it there are
architects and there are gardeners an
architect will need that blueprint to
build what it is they're going to build
he said I'm a gardener I plant a seed
and I tend it and nurse it and I watch
it grow and there are architects who
will do that beat sheet and will do it
brilliantly and and I'm so I'm not
knocking it and then there are gardeners
and I guess I'm a gardener I just kind
of let the idea it there and I tended it
and I didn't I take good care of it
make sure it gets all the water and Sun
and I watch it grow